okay let's go to checklist item number
47.
do you have a plan
to give each employee the right amount
of equity do you know how much equity to
give to your early hires this is where
working with your attorneys and your
venture capitalists can come in handy
putting aside co-founders for a second
there is a schedule as the company grows
of how to
give this equity if a person is coming
in as a
co-founder and you're splitting it three
ways and they're they're at inception
and they're all vesting
you know
four co-founders 25 each and then
you give 10 to the employee stock option
pool you give
20 to your investors everybody takes a
30 haircut 30 percent off of
25
you get the idea
uh you're going to start
getting down into the teens and then
eventually each of the four co-founders
going to own 4-5 percent of the company
if it's two they might own ten percent
each by the time the company gets sold
or grows public uh if it's a solo
co-founder they could own as much as 15
to 25 of the company very rarely happens
um
there are
tons of websites that will break this
down for you you need only do a google
search uh or look on those websites
but senior senior engineers uh in the
early stage they could get 50 bips to
one percent
a vp you know somebody in a top 10
position uh like a cto vp in the early
days would get low single digits one two
three four
again investing over four years
people who are junior engineers they
might get 10 25 bips mid-level engineer
2550 bips when they say bips that means
fractions of a percentage so 50 bips is
half a percentage point 25 bits is a
quarter of a percentage point so not one
percent 50.50
uh and then you know other folks my
junior people might get a token
five to ten bips
er
it's it's very limited equity so you
really want to be smart with it and then
you want to look
as time goes on and say hey when do we
need to ask our board to give us more
equity because you
blow out your esop employee stock option
pool that first estop should last you
through the series a maybe the series a
you would top it off five percent
and then that would come either before
or after the financing some of the
investors if they're giving you a series
a term sheet says we want you to take
everybody on the cap table takes the
five percent hit then we put our money
in so they're not buying 20 of your
company and then immediately losing a
point
right so they want the equity refresh to
happen before that so there are little
issues like that that people negotiate
on the margins
but
you want to be generous but realistic
and you want to have a plan for where
this is going to get you and that's
where having a great board and advisors
and people have done it before
comes in really handy if you go to this
week in startups.com basics we did a
stock options episode with becky degraw
from wilson sancini amazing episode
an amazing uh takeaway from that
was
selecting for your 83b provision this is
crucial for founders
employee stock options because it gives
you the option to pay taxes on the total
fair market value of your stock options
at the time of the granting if you don't
elect this option you're going to owe
taxes on your stock
after every new round of fundraising
it's a really
challenging thing just bring up 83b with
your startup lawyer so you understand it
besting schedule
uh four-year commitment that means you
divide the number of options into four
years that you're going to get that
amount per year but a one-year cliff so
you get nothing until month 12. after
month 12 you might invest monthly or
quarterly in other words
you would take
1 48
of the option grant so if you had
let's say
0.98 just to make it easy point nine
eight percent of the company 48 months
means you're getting two bips a month
so after you get that first year then
you get two bips a month what that means
is it's being fairer to both parties if
you don't stick around a month a year
you're that lame and or we're that lame
as the company that you don't want to
stay you shouldn't be on the cap table
but if you do get to month 13 we had a
good enough time to get to know you you
had a good enough time to get to know us
that's plenty of time you get that big
25 equity grant and then after that
you go monthly so that if you were to
leave a month seven
you're not sticking around to month 25
which is in the bad interest of
everybody if you shouldn't be there
right you don't want a dysfunctional
employee who's sticking around for a
long time i actually in my venture firm
i have people investing in six month
clips
uh and year clips for the funds why do i
do it that way
well i want people to take a ten year
view of working in venture capital not a
monthly view if you're in it for monthly
you're in the wrong thing you have to
think in a decade like i do i think in
two decade periods anybody who's working
for me on the venture side should be
thinking in a decade long period of
building a venture firm to last
and building a syndicate to last at
thesyndicate.com and building wealth
that is generational i want people on my
team thinking about
making millions of dollars tens of
millions eventually
and moving up the stack from us
researchers to associates to principals
to managing directors so that they can
eventually you know buy a million dollar
multi-million dollar home you can only
do that if you're around for 10 years
because these investments take 10 years
to mature and you have to invest them
you get the idea
so
some people do five-year grants now to
keep people even more invested it's
interesting stuff you can build an org
chart with your board this is like board
level discussions that you'll get good
at eventually
number 48 on checklist you know when to
start thinking about culture day one
day one think about the culture you want
and the culture should be
about you and the founders what makes
you want to come to work every day you
do not have to make a culture that is
for everybody that's a mistake you want
a culture that works for you and your
co-founders
and then employees second why
if the employees love the culture and
you don't you're gonna quit
i need you to come to work every day the
founders come to work every day if you
work hard and you believe in being
relentless
great if you on the other hand
are believe in six weeks of vacation and
people turning off their computers at
five and not checking email on the
weekends and life work balance and you
have the opposite of that going on at
your company in either situation you now
have conflict and dissonance your
employees want life work balance you are
working every weekend and nobody's
responding to your emails and slack at 9
00 pm
you believe in taking the weekends off
and stopping work at five and you got
go-getters on your team or emailing you
at night to close a contract and
over the weekend and then they're like
well this person's not moving fast
enough i've lost employees because i
didn't move fast enough and i've lost
employees because i moved too fast
it's like goldilocks some bosses are too
hot some are too cold you got to get to
that just right moment the just right
moment happens because of alignment and
you got to write it down so for me
i like people who
do not need to be managed i like people
who manage themselves
at a certain point when we were doing
more remote work and i was trying to
manage more and more people i said i
want a culture where everybody comes
into slack every day and says a
transparent culture this is the three or
four bullet points i'm working on at the
end of the day they say this is what i
got accomplished today and they linked
to the documents in notion or
spreadsheets on google sheets
uh or the asana board or crm system for
sales whatever it is so that everybody
was super informed i had two people who
refuse to do it they don't work for me
anymore
listen right now